said in New York City can we talk about
that where you see somebody wearing a go
a Ghost Face Killer mask brandishing a
knife yeah you're not going to think
twice you're going to be like I just got
to get to work out of my way yeah it
turns on my corner all the time right so
what was it like having New York be a
character in this film it raises the
stakes because this city is what you
said you know like everyone's kind of
doing their own thing and someone can be
dying in the corner and people will be
like get out of my way you know like I
gotta go I've heard that happen to me
I'm like lost some people are like can
you move sorry yeah I'm walking here Ms
Ortega said it's one of the best sets
one of the most funds she's ever had on
a set you agree I agree how is making
this thing fun for you guys making a
horror movie you wouldn't think this and
I didn't think it before I joined this
franchise it's the most kid-like fun
that you can have while you're acting as
a kid it's like reverting back to when
you're six or seven years old